what do you guys see some like a young
guy you young how old are you 24 what
are you do when you live 24 what's that
look
like 24 what do you do you work school
real St you sell some
houses you have your own firm
development you have a real estate
development firm 24 years old that's it
you started a real estate developing
firm at 24 years old by
yourself no no one fames in it your
dad's
[Applause]
in that's the craziest thing I've ever
heard
about he has a job he just works at a
job there's nothing wrong with that his
dad is a real estate development firm
and he works there there's nothing wrong
with that he probably works from home he
jerks off and he goes into the living
room and signs on and does a zoom
meeting it's
like but I asked him when he did for a
living and with a straight face with the
straight face he looked in my eyes and
he goes I have a real estate develop
F I'm like well you started it he goes
yes I
did and then I go so no one else in your
family works there and he go my
dad so in does your dad work for you are
you you employ the old man is that what
it is is he running on tough times
you're like pop listen in between
surfing and getting high in the
I'm started a real estate development
firm and I'd like you to work for
me I know you've had a tough time and I
want to bring you into my thing that I'm
doing I've got a real estate development
firm yeah well I got it well we were
skating in a parking
lot in atenas and I turned to a few
idiots that I was standing with I we
decided to stop taking fent all for an
hour and start a real estate development
F we sck over selling retail real estate
residential or commercial we said that's
a waste of our [__]
time we want to do big business malls
strip malls hotels major real estate
projects so I've got a real estate
construction business right now that
I've started my myself I want you to be
involved in
it it's the craziest thing I've ever had
the confidence of a white 24 year-old
from California is
insane
insane it's
amazing it's amazing it's like he's like
our governor is a six-year-old [__]
boy who lives in a Vineyard I can be a
fake real estate
developer how just be a fake real estate
developer and the way he said it to me
too was like I wouldn't understand it
he's like what are you you're not going
to understand this you st
down you stupid clown you won't get it I
develop real
estate I'm a
[Applause]
genius I'm a [__] I look at an area
just look at the numbers
immediately I'm a [__]
genius you know here's what the job
really is the job really is
this his father sat him down one they
think K table L I don't know what
happened with that girl but we've sent
two
lawyers he sent two Warriors to St Louis
of BU to gave you out whatever the hell
you did I don't know what you did but
that girl
disappeared now I'm not accusing you of
anything I love you no matter what
happened we've all made mistakes
now it's awkward for you to go back to
school we spent a lot of money keeping
this out of the press okay and she was
half made of American how do you think
that looks
you think that
looks they're saying in the paper that
you raped and killed the Native American
indigenous woman my
son he goes you have one last
chance you're going to work in my real
estate
to there one last chance you stunned B
you're a stunn b
rapist and probably a murderer too you
probably kill people and
then few months later he's in a comedy
show and some goes what are you doing he
goes I own a real estate
[Applause]
develop this went very well going to
take you to different
towns we're going to do this tell Dad
you're going to take you got a few
months to go on
tour I got something good Happening
Here what you guys what's what's thanks
you guys brothers friends friends what's
Thanksgiving like tomorrow at the
house CH where do you live what
part s the
projects is ranch cantre nice I don't
know all I know if it's nice here is La
Hoya because that's all I know cuz I'm
from New York and you don't think if San
Diego's a real
place you don't care but you
begrudgingly tolerate San Francisco but
um good for you good for you hey dude
it's not easy to be 24 years old and buy
a house in Ran
s that's not [__] easy dude after you
murdered a Native American woman St
there as a dismo and then probably ate
her you sick cable
[__]
some of the women here are just like I
don't know about
[Applause]
this some people here by accident you
can feel that you always feel the B
someone's here
like what's here's what's funny these
seats are more expensive than the
back so he's going to like get in his
car and I spent that extra $10
they called a rapist and a
murderer